Hi! I'm Naomi, and I'm very excited to show you the world's greatest attractions.
The Kansas City Library Parking Garage,...
...located in the heart of downtown Kansas City, Missouri,...
...signifies extraordinary architectural design.
It was built to rejuvenate the metropolis area...
...and encourage residents young and old alike to take advantage of its books and further knowledge.
The exterior portrays book bindings of several of the world's most famous writings...
...made to depict a large bookshelf.
The building stands approximately 25 feet tall and each book is nine feet in width.
There are 22 books in total,...
...the widely ranged titles chosen by Kansas City citizens...
...for an entirely personified approach to design.
Thank you for watching our travel video series.
See you next time.